[Music]
push the wrong button and this robot
known as Big Bird could destroy an
entire pallet of Steel chainsaws so
trainees like will grouse always work
under supervision but grellus is no
beginner he's already into his third
year of training alongside fellow
apprentices he meticulously cuts out
volts was micro metric precision I like
working with my hands I like making
things and when I found out what the
apprenticeship did I thought this is a
good place for me to get advancement
within steel so I applied for it and
luckily I was one of few selected to get
in
training with supervisor Thomas Cunha
takes four years then gross can call
himself a mechatronic this combination
of mechanic electrician and programmer
is well established in Germany but it's
only now reaching the u.s. Wil's bolts
are now part of this robots are anyone
who manages to build a little bird is
ready to face today's production
industry
Thomas Cunha adopted this approach to
practical training in Germany high
school doesn't teach you to think in
micrometers in a hundredth or a tenth of
a millimeter and that's what we do here
but there's a big problem Cunha can't
find enough suitable candidates for his
program to ensure basic know how he
often takes on ex-military staff as old
as 40 another problem is that industrial
work so-called blue-collar work often
has a bad reputation
unfortunately 30 40 years ago in the
United States it was decided that blue
collar was a thing of the past and
everyone should be sent to college now
they're realizing they have a lack of
skilled workers and that they need this
combination of theory and practice that
you find in Germany and Europe Kuna had
to be especially creative for the
theoretical models and exploit all the
available opportunities in Virginia
Beach
the city is known for one feature in
particular it is officially home to the
world's longest recreational beach with
a 5 kilometer long promenade along the
Atlantic Ocean but it's not just
tourists and hotels chainsaw
manufacturers steel also managed to find
the theoretical know-how to complement
the practical training will attends the
local community college four days a week
the classes he takes fit his training
program and they provide him with
theoretical background like courses in
engineering dynamics gross is the only
one in his class who was part of the
steel program most of the students here
study only Theory wills daily schedule
as a trainee is demanding but he's
holding up well he used to be a
production line worker at steel and he
says this is much better
well since I'd been trying to study
towards that field of degree I kind of
knew I was going to be getting into some
involvement but not this not this level
of complication it is really different
for me yeah I am yeah so it definitely
pays off for the trainees but what about
the company itself manager Simon dance
often drops by the production line he's
trying to improve employee development
and he wants feedback from his employees
the u.s. makes up Steel's most important
market outside Europe the tools produced
here generate an annual turnover of 716
million euros steel products are
relatively high priced but Nantz knows
that only good quality will keep
attracting buyers he's convinced the
training program is a key factor it's
it's an investment in employees skills
and when we can invest long-term in
employees not six months down the road
but six years down the road it's gonna
make a difference in the product and
it's going to make a difference for the
customer
the chainsaw is made here in Virginia
Beach don't carry the made in Germany
label but future skilled workers like
will grouse will make sure that these
tools will work just as well as the ones
that are made in Germany
[Music]